[Applause]
yes yes yes
how are you
fantastic so glad to be here i know we
were having a teta tet backstage saying
it's so crazy because i was lucky enough
to be on an episode of beat bobby flay
the best you were the best your energy
on that show just i mean like this show
just kind of brings it like to the nth
level it's amazing
well
your audience you know which i think of
as as guests um you're even more than an
audience and um
but it's raucous over there it is
raucous i mean you know it's like people
get very enthusiastic when they smell
good things in the kitchen i mean this
place smells really good right now oh
yes it does you know we got we got
burgers flying all over the place here
and that's you know it's you know
burgers always smell good no matter what
you know when i walked onto the set and
i've been so looking forward to this
segment um well first of all uh this
cookbook is genius oh thank you so much
it's just a genius concept and today
we're gonna make your famous pimento
cheese juicy lucy yeah juice i had never
and
so
for um for people that don't know what a
juicy lucy is it's basically an inverted
cheeseburger so the cheese is on the
inside so it's yeah people love mmm yeah
i'm i'm salivating you're already
tasting that burger and actually i had
never really made a juicy lucy before i
got challenged on beat bobby flay really
no i'm not like an old school like
cheeseburger guy i put the cheese on top
of the burger you know but you know in
minneapolis yeah which is where this
thing was
uh born in a bar
um probably very late at night one night
let's put the cheese inside the burger
um you know after a couple of shots of
tequila yeah you come up with some
really good but but it's a pretty genius
um idea you know so that you you
guarantee that that sort of meltiness
when you bite into the burger and that
juiciness you guarantee you're not going
to have a dry burger for sure i mean i'm
so excited because i don't think i've
ever had a juicy lucy and today's your
day i'm i mean i'm salivating as i say
it i like it's i'm so excited for this i
love the detail in the book also that
you can see where you won and where you
didn't i lose plenty and and a lot of
times people come up to me on the street
and be like you know i watch beat bobby
flay you never lose and i'm like you
don't watch enough because i lose a lot
i have seen it but i think it averages
around 70 of the time it's like 65 70
something in there how do you feel when
you do
uh when you are defeated i actually
i mean
i i and i mean this wholeheartedly i
actually love it because
you know
i created this show for two reasons to
hang out with friends like you
and to cook and those are the two things
i love to do most
and then everything else kind of happens
around me and i created it because i
wanted to create a stage for other chefs
from around the country who might not
get that opportunity all the time i as
like one of your biggest fans also felt
that with throwdown oh yes i mean you've
been doing that you've been
making it an even playing field and
helping other people get into that
spotlight for many years yeah and also
it's a it's a much bigger deal when the
the
the opposing chef where the visiting
chef beats me especially in their
community like if i win it's like ho ho
bobby one who cares but if the if the
the chef who came on and challenged me
wins and they're from some small town
you know somewhere in the united states
it's a big deal to them and like the
local press goes crazy they have viewing
parties in their restaurants it's so
much fun yes exactly i think that's what
they call a win-win yes exactly it's a
win all the way up seriously
all right well
we are in thrifty week i'm a major
vintage shopper a major gently used
second hand up cycling i didn't know i
was up cycling my whole life you go
antique you go antiquing oh my god it's
why i drive a minivan also because i
have kids and dogs um so but there's
usually like a couch stuffed in with the
dogs or a painting i never i'm not
hauling
some
vintage so so you so you go around like
these swap meets they call them and
stuff like that and like do you like
poster things and stuff and all that i
mean or do you just you know what is it
as is i'll tell you something about a
pulse string okay tell me
it's not cheap i know it's like
reupholstering something can be as
expensive if not more if you're going to
pay a couch
whoa on recovering it same with the
chair cool you think you find an old
wicker piece fun cheap no
not if you're going to upholster it
bonus segment we're talking about
reupholstering well
[Music]